free
Palestine here's clip two of Ben at
Oxford over the course of the last 50
years thanks entirely to the magic of
capitalism so you can't take the
benefits and then reject the downsides I
don't think it works that way all right
thank you and free
[Applause]
[Music]
Palestine Whi which
part
really
it's it's it's it's it's it's it's a
it's a serious question what what is
it um I'm not going to comment that I
mean I saw you say from The River To The
Sea so you can just say it out loud yeah
from The River To The Sea yeah there we
go okay I appreciate I appreciate the
idea that the Jewish State should be
wiped completely off the map with the
concominant loss of life but we're
worried about climate change and the
humanitarian aspects of climate change
over the course of the next 100 years
sure okay okay thank you in some weird
respect I simp sympathize with these
kids who brains have been so obliterated
that with that girl she doesn't know
what she's doing and she there's a shame
attached to it when she put the mic down
and kind of look down and then she talks
about River to the Sea because she
doesn't know what she's saying like and
if she really thought about it if they
really thought about so is what you want
to do is kill 8 million Jews in in the
Middle East uh and you'd probably have
to kill about two million Arab Israelis
who are peacefully living there as well
some of whom are fighting in the Army
right now in the BNS and the and the
Christian Israelis and everything else
they don't know what they are saying and
and Ben it's not easy you know as I gave
Bill Mar credit uh the other day Ben
probably doesn't want me to say this but
I saw Ben the other day I saw him a few
days after that at the at the Jordan
event at the O2 and you know emotions
were running high and I was thrilled to
see when they brought Ben on stage when
Jordan it was a surprise that Ben was
there and when when Jordan brought Ben
on stage and the Applause 20,000 people
for Ben Ben gets big Applause you know
anywhere he goes but there a little
something extra to the Applause because
it wasn't just oh Ben Shapiro's here
it's like he's kind of like the number
one Jew at the moment right and he's the
number one person fighting this stuff on
the front lines and there was an extra
feeling in that room in London which
London's dealing with all sorts of
craziness right now about that so that
was very enlightening see but I know
it's taking a toll on Ben as it's taking
a toll on
everybody